[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is my chat
with the comedy Legend and the only
former U.S senator currently on tour Al
Franken that's the name of his Tour by
the way go to alfrankin.com if you want
to see the man live he's so funny so
smart he's so interesting the only
former U.S senator currently on tour
tour go to alfrankin.com to get tickets
today also maybe both go to
petehomes.com thank you to everybody
that was in Toronto Atlantic City and
Boston those shows were awesome up next
is Chicago for three nights at the Den
for three shows go to petehomes.com for
that it's going to be so great to be
back in Chicago followed by San
Francisco Portland Seattle Atlanta
Charlotte and Washington DC it's been
awesome awesome awesome I'm so pleased
with this new hour hope to see some
weirdos out on the road it always means
so much when you can make it and also
and also if you like this show why not
try a Pete's pick a pizza pick you heard
me right a Pete's pick what's a pizza
pick I only do ads for things that I
actually use and I actually love and
there is no product that I actually use
and actually love maybe more than magic
mind magic mind is not an energy drink
it is the world's first productivity
drink it has adaptogens which help you
cope with stress as nootropics which
helps your brain function at its Optimum
level and it has just a little bit of
caffeine from matcha which which by the
way I should say and it tastes great a
lot of people don't like the taste of
matcha it tastes great because it's
sweetened with honey it is incredible it
is designed to be taken in the morning
with your coffee because the adaptogens
are going to round the edge of that
energy boost you get from the coffee
it's going to smooth it out the
nootropics and the adaptogens and the to
help you get into that flow state it
doesn't make me wired it gets me dialed
in frankly drinking coffee by itself or
too much coffee certainly my fists close
up I can't focus I can't sit still magic
mind is the opposite of that it is
creatorade like instead of Gatorade it's
creatorade it's wonderful if you do
anything that involves your brain if
you're working in a creative field if
you're writing if you're podcasting if
you're like me doing stand-up comedy I
travel with magic mind Val and I are
currently in New Mexico I have it in my
bag just so I can take it in the morning
to feel fantastic give me a mood
elevation it gets me dialed in and helps
me get into the flow of my day
especially when I'm trying to do do
something creative you get 30 percent
more done on average five to seven hours
is how long it lasts of 30 percent more
productivity after you drink it try it
for three to seven in days for
continuous use it's even easier as you
go it builds on itself to get into that
flow State and there's a money back
guarantee any first purchase will be
refunded no questions asked if it
doesn't meet your expectations plus as
if that wasn't enough they're currently
doing a 14 days of magic challenge try
magic mind drink magic mine for 14 days
and post on social about it and for
every 10 000 views that it gets they'll
donate ten dollars towards the
reforestation of the Amazon rainforest
this is a cause very close to me it
should be close to all of us the Amazon
rainforest is like the lungs of our
planet and it's absolute Madness that we
are chopping it down so this is what
we're doing to help every million views
for the hashtag 14 days of magic will
bring one thousand dollars donated by
Magic mind so give it a try post about
it and save the rainforce and mean it
doesn't really get any better than that
help your creativity get into that flow
State and help save the planet and you
can get a discount and show your support
of the show go to
www.magicmind.com weird and use promo
code weird to get a limited 20 off your
first order that's magicmine.com weird
and promo code weird to get 20 off your
first order and show your support of
this show next up is our friends at Ned
Ned our make our makers of the best full
spectrum hemp collection they have not
just CBD and CB G oils but these are
specifically dialed in and designed
they're like the designer hemp oil
people for example in the morning I like
taking it in the morning I take my Ned d
stress blend this is my ritual a ritual
is obviously you know this it's a daily
practice that helps you stay grounded an
intentional act to take a few minutes to
reconnect and take care of yourself get
present think positive and connect to
your North Star and for me it's all
about de-stressing so I can drop into my
morning drop into what it is I have to
do without feeling overwhelmed it's a
natural path to stealing your Waters and
getting back to easier times the blend
is dominated dominant excuse me and CBG
often referred to the mother of all
cannabinoids and CBD both extracted from
the world's purest full spectrum hemp
and features a Botanical infusion of
ashwagandha cardamom and cinnamon so
this is incredible for your body
incredible for your brain I find it to
be very mood elevating rounding the
edges of all my stress and getting me
into that place where maybe I'm afraid
literally of answering emails are
sitting down to work on something I've
been putting off the de-stress blend by
Ned is absolutely a secret weapon to
naturally get over those feelings and
get into my day and get productive at
night I also take another ritual the Ned
sleep blend so many people are taking
Pharmaceuticals at night to unwind I
love to do it with something natural and
earth-based and backed by science it
helps me relax it helps me fall asleep
faster and wake up feeling fantastic
with the Ned sleeping so you see what I
mean it's not just hemp oil these are
mixed with other Botanicals to help you
get the most out of them it is
incredible and they help me be obviously
they help me with everything they help
me be a better parent because I'm better
rested they help me wear my where my
thing go where am I thinking
I'm Letting Go I have my notes here they
help me with so many things basically I
want you to try it show your support of
the show be a better parent be a better
worker and be a better you with a more
focused mild gentle feeling that you get
from these wonderful products be the
best version of yourself and get 15 off
Ned products with promo code weird Go to
hellowned.com weird or enter code weird
at checkout that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d.com slash weird to get
15 off thank you to Ned for sponsoring
the show and offering our listeners a
natural remedy for some of life's most
common health issues last but not least
you can see me wearing it right now is
my Apollo neuro Apollo neuro is a
wearable tech what does it do it helps
your body recover from stress it's like
a wearable hug that can help you relax
sleep focus and be more active and uses
touch therapy vibrations into your
nervous system that help you feel safe
and in control we're currently traveling
I had it on relax and unwind the entire
flight really helps my body not feel
that like oh god I've been on a plain
feeling that I get now that I'm 43 and
as soon as I get off I put on rebuild
and recover it helps my body acclimate
to where I am and just not miss a beat
in my day it's worn on the wrist or the
ankle the Apollo neuro delivers gentle
soothing vibrations to train your
nervous system to recover and rebalance
after stress if it did one of these
things it would be incredible but it
does all of these things with the
different settings energy and wake up
it's like espresso but you don't have to
drink espresso social and open is often
what I have it on when I'm recording
this podcast clear and focused has been
clinically shown to help with symptoms
of ADD rebuilding the cover that's the
setting for after I visit my parents
meditation and mindfulness helps me drop
into deeper and more helpful productive
wonderful life-affirming meditation than
I've ever had in my life relax and
unwind I put it on that at night helps
me shake off the day and ease down power
down Val and I caught the try to stay
awake setting and sleep and renew I
literally wear this when I'm asleep I
charge it when I'm in the shower I sleep
with it and if I wake up in the middle
of the night hit the two buttons re-run
the program and it lulls me back to
sleep it actually trains the nervous
system to cope with stress better over
time the more you use it the better it
works and it was developed by a
neuroscientist and a board-certified
psychiatrist which means this is not
found in a crystal shop next to a magic
crystal ball this is real science that
they've been studying the impacts of
chronic stress in humans for nearly 15
years Apollos effects on sleep stress
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and real world studies and you can get
10 off and show you supported this show
by going to apollonuro.com weird that's
Apollo
n-euro.com slash weird alright everybody
hope to see you out on the road it would
mean so much go to petehomes.com for all
of my tour tickets and in the meantime
enjoy the incredible Al Franken and go
see him on the road alfrankin.com
alright get into it yeah
marketing I mean here it's it's an old
stand-up bit I had about uh when people
go here we are talking about it
and it always bothered me when people
would say here we are talking about it
and I was like that would only be true
if we said but here we are against our
will buying dozens of cases of liquid
death water you know what I mean
although now I kind of disagree with the
premise because yeah we'll just start
oh and please sit as far back as you can
put your feet on it it's like a
sleepover it's the filthiest couch in
the world you're so welcome do it like
an airplane
that oh yeah here have another one this
is oh my God I just threw a pillow and
it went right behind you there you are
is that a half Lotus you're doing it's
weird I always thought this was good
that I was flexible and then I had a
masseuse finally say your ligaments are
too loose
Jesus Christ the one the one thing I
took proud so I'm pride of regarding
your body regarding my body yeah our
bodies are uh Shame Shame spirals yes
I'm just going like I'm sure and you
know but
I'm flexible I actually I hate to yes
and your shame
but one of my first thoughts was I did
think you were taller I want do you get
that all the time yes I I hate that I'm
sorry well I hate that I'm being typical
Ryan's in a funny story well you
actually have to go to a break real
quick yeah in one second uh this episode
yes please tell the story please tell
the story
um first day I'm in the Senate
I do my uh
so I get sworn in United States uh so I
get sworn in and go back to my uh office
do some stuff there then I got votes and
I'm sitting on the subway
other Subways between the capital and
the different Office Buildings that's
fun and seeing right across these little
Subways and so you can still pee in them
uh is it filters frowned upon
I've never seen anyone do it nor did
they they keep good care of the subway
okay good in terms of that is this the
subway that Kevin Spacey pushed uh his
assistant remember in House of Cards he
murders his assistant I didn't no I was
not I didn't you don't have to watch
that as a member of this no no
but I I don't think well it's possible
it's possible who knows I I you know uh
I've never seen this that happen so
anyway so I'm going back for my first
votes and sitting across to me is Chuck
Grassley from Iowa and he's only 75 at
the time
10.75. he says and he looks at me and
he's just staring at me and finally goes
oh you look just like you look on TV
meaning
I look like so I I say to him well
there's a reason for that
he's meant it quite literally he totally
there you are oh you look just like you
look on TV and I said well there's a
reason for that but some people say that
I'm shorter than I look on TV he goes oh
yeah well guess what they say about me
they say well that you're taller than
you look on TV he goes yeah hedge and
all that
I said well because you're taller when
you look on TV he goes oh yeah well
guess what else they say about me that
you're friendlier than the yellow
country yeah how'd you know that
and I said well you know it wouldn't
hurt to smile every once while when
you're on TV we'll normally want to talk
about
pretty serious
so I say well you could smile at the
beginning
and then get be serious
when you're talking about the serious
stuff and then smile at the end he goes
lots of really good idea doesn't
Washington have why do we need former
SNL star Al Franken to come into this
man's life to tell him this is your
business this gives you some idea of the
caliber of the people I'm working with
is what I'm saying smile at the
beginning yeah yeah well normally when
I'm talking more is pretty sure well you
can smile at the beginning
that's really a good idea
I thought politics please sip your
liquid Death Mountain Water
um here we are talking about it
did you Belgium it's not oh I see you
I'm sorry yeah no there's what they're
going for Al Franken dies hilariously no
my improv training
what can I say of which I had none is
that true no I didn't Tom Davis did your
writing partner my writing but my my
start in high school your life partner
well he's he's dead now unfortunately
yes yeah old homes they could have dug a
little deeper in their research
[Laughter]
I didn't know the name and that that was
your writing partner yeah yeah yeah we
went to high school together okay and
then we were two of the original SNL
writers yep and yeah making like 300 a
week I believe that he did the research
Boomer and watch this we're at the
beginning
so that is yeah yeah yeah we were hired
as one Apprentice writer the two of us
so you made very few bones when the we
got there at the beginning the first day
of the show first meeting of the show
really I can't really July right after
July 4th weekend 75. first guy we met at
the elevator was Michael Donahue
great brilliant dark writer and he says
right away he says to us how much you
guys getting paid right so we tell them
what's New York people talk yeah so he
says
I spend that much money every week to
shine my cat's shoes not bad pretty good
pretty good I wonder and I go like oh
this is going to be a great show
it's true I'm gonna ask you something
else yeah and I want your real opinion
sure your comedy man did he have the
line ready because he knew it was little
or did he come up with it between oh no
no 300 I'm sure off the cuff I spend
more to shine my cat's shoes was a line
he had at the ready you think he added
the ready he had the red yeah yeah
they're ready not that genius
it's still I did a roast once still it's
a good line that he had at the ready so
there you go I did a roast where I
wanted to make fun of my friend for
being broke I still feel bad about it
and I go I won't say the guy's name Mike
bridenstein I'm just kidding
it wasn't my grandson but I I let's say
the guy's name was Mike I go Mike I have
your rent on me I thought that was funny
it's kind of mean that's good but it's
like it's so little because he's so
broke yeah you get it yeah yeah why am I
explaining this to you yeah I I do like
I like I do like uh I have your rent on
me no my cat's shoes I mean that's the
winner it's sort of hard to follow it
might go down to you anyway so that was
it yeah yeah we let well okay I want to
I obviously I'm excited to talk to you I
actually had a stress stream about it
for some reason I had this dream
first of all you were like Nordic you
know when your dreams just get the gas
soda complete yeah that works where's
that you know sure yeah maybe that was
it maybe my subconscious is a genius but
you were like or just Garden variety
subconscious yeah like all of our
subconsciousness would make such a
profound leap no well that's good I'm
gonna go with genius I don't know why
you tried to ride my genius genius can't
I have that can't I you haven't yeah do
an edit here that's great
wow
oh God I'm gonna skip the rest of the
details for fear of mockery JK
I'm not afraid of Margaret but it was
you on the podcast Katie was there
um who was it what's his name I'm
blanking on his name it doesn't matter
there was another podcast host in the
room with me and I must be nervous about
talking to you for all the things you've
done because I've never had like a
stress dream about a guest but there you
were at Nordic right and the guess Ryan
sickler it was Ryan sickler who's
another comedian he kept like farting
into the mic and stuff
it's gonna help me
that's my closer I guess it's more of an
opener
um
that's what I've been doing wrong crap
crap is the closer
farting is the opener okay I everything
I do I think of in a 3X structure but it
must be because you know I thought it
was just everything is scatological
anything I can make scatological I will
in a three active sketch sketch idea
scattles and Skittles but they're little
rabbit turds you know rabbit turns sort
of perfect little scattles that's that's
brilliant you were gonna critique it you
may no I wasn't I just was wondering how
to blow smoke up your ass on that joke
and I I kind of you didn't like scattles
what you've heard it before no no it's
good it's fine
I'm mad at you I'm not mad at you but I
I I really I'm just trying to blow smoke
up your ass and be like we've never had
a senator on is that true they're so
forgettable like that one on the subway
and uh somebody who's had these two
lives so I'm excited to have you and I
don't want Ryan sickler farting into the
mic because podcasts can sort of be like
some of them have turned into morning
radio a little bit we're like
like slide whistles and I hit a button
and there's a toilet it's funny because
I do
a podcast yeah and what's it called it's
called the Al Franken podcast edit that
out and what edit that out
[Laughter]
no uh it'll be good because you're
listening
no my listener and I said you're
listeners okay Jesus right I didn't know
I know minnesotans said weird things but
I didn't know they dropped the S on
plurals
go back to the tape
okay
uh what was what the hell was I saying
what was I saying you were saying you
loved scattles the the boob Skittles
that is a [__] great joke
no I was saying we've never had a
senator uh a former Senator however
you're supposed yeah you're a senator
for forever I'm always going to think of
you Senator on the show and podcasts
former centers former centers right now
okay I like Senator better but also that
uh podcasts sort of turn into morning
radio and you're saying the Al Franken
podcast oh yeah yeah yeah what's weird
about my podcast is that I do public a
lot of public policy I do it once a week
so I don't do news of the day but I you
know I'm steeped in public policy and
politics and stuff like that but I also
have comedians so I just I'm dropping
one I don't know timing if you're
dropping this but uh uh this coming
Sunday it doesn't matter uh with Sarah
Silverman and this her second time on
and I've had you know like Conan and
Letterman but like this past few weeks I
had Paul Krugman the Nobel prize-winning
Economist has the New York Times uh
column and so and I had Neil cacciol who
was former solicitor general who if your
listeners watch MSNBC or that kind of
thing he is on analyzing but and and I
had him on talking what Garland's
options are American Airlines options
are and then I have you know Chris Rock
and yeah so it's a little bifurcated but
um but I also there's more humor in my
my podcast than in most public policy
podcast yes but you're even in your
podcast you're saying it reflects your
life you you have your two major
highways most people just don't care
about this [__] you know I care about
this [__] so yeah you know well you're
oh go ahead no I'm gonna double Mike
well you know after uh no after
um uh George Floyd I had Charles Ramsey
who was chief of police for Washington
and and Philadelphia talk about police
reform that's the kind of thing I do and
then I'll have Dana Carvey right
who's quite easy to get
Dana's available it was hilarious I
don't know if we need to go that far
okay
let's not compare
comedians just kidding he's one of the
funniest people yeah who's ever lived
and when he did this podcast I'll never
forget you were were you taking that
we were at the three and a half hour
mark don't worry we're not going to go
that long today but Dana wouldn't stop
until he closed like he wanted to close
it on a big laugh like I started to land
the plane and he and here I am with a
legend someone who really inspired me as
a as a performer and he was like I don't
know I don't know if we've done enough
like we like he wanted to find another
bit Yeah well I had the first time I had
him on was right after HW died yes so he
had a kind of relationship with him
because oh wow I mean this is such a
different time and different president
you know I wrote a lot of those
Baldwin's not hanging out with Trump is
that what you mean well there's a whole
different thing but we but he
he did this hilarious H.W bush yeah but
it was kind of gentle in an odd way but
hilarious and by the way
it was so his HW was so funny that
Downey and I Jim Downey uh the famously
brilliant writer from SNL did years and
years on the show and he and I wrote a
lot of political stuff together we would
write these coal openings it was like a
crutch because we could just okay we can
open the show with Dana at the at the
desk you know yeah and we would have to
tell them between dress and Air
you're getting too many laughs
it's taking too long it's ruining not
the length it was the through line where
the the
we would write things that meant
something
well you were trying to get a message
across well not a message but at least
tonight you know it'd be like uh you
know uh this
hypodermic needle was found right across
the street from the White House in
Lafayette Park
this vial of empty vial crack on the
White House lawn this bag of cocaine
three feet from my desk
so there'd be like a thing and hit so
many laughs in between
that you'd lose it that you'd kind of
lose and and here's the Brilliance of
Dana
he knew exactly what he was doing and he
did he made the exact
adjustment between dress and error
really I'm not going to get a laugh on
any you know that hand gesture he did
over there done that thing over there
and he could just at will at will and I
I don't think I've ever told a performer
on SNL ever other than that stopped
getting so many laughs wow like Reign it
in Carvey you're ruining the flow well
the through lines you know yeah no I
understand yeah yeah no I I I'm sort of
someone that is that funny when he
didn't want to end I took comfort in it
because I went it doesn't really matter
I always think of the story Oprah tells
she's interviewing Barack Obama and at
the end of the interview they go to
Commercial and he leans over and he goes
was that okay
he wants to know if he did okay that's a
good Obama well he finally he's warming
up to me I mean nobody told him how much
of the show is just telling me that I'm
valid and worthy it was a very good
Obama
Dana Carvey my Obama famously I've
always said he's my Obama he also has
that insecurity meaning like I wanna
I want to Razzle Dazzle at the end and I
took some comfort in that you know what
I mean like doesn't matter how far
you've gone
you still would like or that's just
being a professional comedian who's
brilliant and great and has high
standards all of which is what makes you
really good I hear you but if there's
anywhere you could
scoot away and no one would ever bring
it up it's three and a half hours into
this podcast but you know those
standards Dana once said to me there's
no reason to be a comedian unless you
absolutely have to be
that's good that's true yeah and do you
agree you must agree I mean it yeah I
hate to use the word uh well there's no
way to do this this is real like this is
the first 10 years of podcasting it was
only this conversation so I don't mind
in 2022 going back to it but did you
feel called to Comedy
yeah basically
um I was born in 1951 in 57 the Russians
the Soviets put up Sputnik
we were they had nuclear weapons they
were ahead of us in space America was
terrified
my parents sat me and my brother down my
brother's five years older than me said
you boys are going to study math and
science so he can beat the Soviets
and I thought that was a lot of pressure
to put on a six-year-old but
we study math and science I got it he
got he went to MIT
and graduated with degree in physics and
became a photographer
oh boy that's hilarious I I went to
Harvard us at during a period where it
was a lot easier for a white male to get
into Harvard that period was from the
founding of the school you're filling
out the application that says are you
white male and you check yes it goes
yeah skip to page 12. you're like all
right all these other things and uh yeah
that period was from the family at
school until last year yeah it's easier
for white male so and I became a
comedian yeah and it's because I was
majoring in you know taking chemistry
into m M I realized Jesus Christ I can't
do this I don't want to do this career
and so I took a
I took like the psych psychology this
stupid test Minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory
where you answer 500 or you put yes or
no to 502 questions I'm picturing the
kids in stranger things wearing the
gowns in an underground bunker but yeah
keep going okay so and so the only
question I remember
was
I have not had any black and tarry bowel
movements
and the reason I know it's the Minnesota
multiface is that I wrote a kind of a
memoir a couple few years ago and I
looked up black and Terry that question
and the all the Google results were
that's the only question people remember
or from black Minnesota multi-phasic
right um why would that have anything to
do with your personality it's 502
questions so it has one 502nd
value I don't know I don't know oh well
I'll tell you why it doesn't because all
the all the Google thing said the test
was worthless but the results that came
back said be a comedian no it said one
scientist bottom just at the very bottom
number one was camp counselor
and number two was jazz musician and I
had never played an instrument black
antari is a great Blues musician name
[Laughter]
I can't remember whether they answered
yes or no but
I put camp counselor and jazz musician
together and I said oh I it's just
saying I should be a comedian
I think you're absolutely right and it's
funny that we live in this time I'd like
to say that wasn't a racial joke black
and Tori
[Laughter]
is it's funny I I feel like I've kind of
looked in the black and tarry Bell
movements and there's bad reasons to
have them oh my God is there a good
reason of a blackened maybe if you're
sealing up a roof you're doing some roof
work and you run out of materials and
you're like hey Franken
what's your answer on on 502.
damn I wish I had a black guitar
of all the times
smell honey
it'll land it'll
be over there's no rain in here though
yeah it smells like [__] but you're dry
yeah that's what it is rain it'll smell
like [__] again always
I think you're absolutely right jazz
musician and camp counselor is what a
comedian is I guess so but again this is
a worthless test but I just I wanted to
be a comedian so I said comedian right
I hear you yeah I want to do comedy I
think you're right I'm agreeing with you
and I've been doing it in high school
with Tom I've been doing it
you know uh for a number of years we we
were performing at a place called Dudley
Riggs Brave New Workshop while we were
still in high school which is kind of a
third City it was like Second City but
in Minneapolis Del close uh coat you
know there uh he he came up from Chicago
Dell close famously uh was a guru in
improv and especially at Second City yes
but he came up to Minneapolis to train
people really yeah and you studied with
him I did not Tom did okay oh that's
right you have no improv training I have
no improv training but Tom's improv
training was you know Julia Child
bleeding to death you know that sketch
okay Tom and I wrote that
yeah
Aykroyd was Julia and we were looking
for clothes
uh last joke
and when you do improv you're you're
taught to look for objects
and Tom wrote the
um
which was go the phone go to dial 9-1-1
and then she throws it down it's a prop
phone and and then dies
it's a prop phone and Tom found that
object because he did improv which is my
way of saying that all your listeners if
you're interested in doing this do
Improv oh for sure yes absolutely you
know it's funny only until I had done it
many times I had a joke about Rachel Ray
is so sunshining on the show I just want
to see what she would do if she would
cut herself and then only years later
did I go like that's that's Julia Child
that's that sketch you know what I mean
it's like we saw her cut herself on it
Tom and I were watching like the Today
Show for some reason and she was on for
before Thanksgiving and prepping and she
cut herself
and how did she handle it IR well it
wasn't gushing
blood I think
and I don't know use a cheesecloth or
something I can't remember what it is
but we went okay that's a sketch
here's the funny thing about this that
that that thing so we that killed in
dress and we held it
because the blood wasn't
quite right quite right and that's a
special effect job that's a you know
remember the crew
but Tom knew the piece so well
that we just asked the special effects
guy can Tom do it and it was an
insecticide sprayer or something
underneath there oh to to work the blood
and so the thing you see on YouTube
wherever you can see this thing of Julia
Child bleeding death Tom is under the
counter he's timing he's in our timing
and the pressure yeah he's the heart
yeah and he was the heart attack
just a great comedian
you're a poet now you're understanding
that the point of this podcast I
apologize for not getting it until this
minute
now you're in the zone you're in the
zone let me ask you you're the only
we've had many many SNL people on the
show but nobody going back to the
beginning right and what everybody says
about it now is that it's not what it
used to be and when they say that they
mean it's not doing cocaine and staying
up all night
well I think they mean other stuff
sometimes well tell me what you think
they mean and tell me what it was like I
really couldn't be more interested
well I mean
first of all we had seven cast members
now when I look at
the you know they're still announcing
them from Saturday so it's still going
yeah and featuring
yeah still happening right and there's
like 20 or 21 and yeah
um that does a disservice I think to the
those cast members oh yeah and we had
like 12 writers or something like that
and you know if there's a sketch and
someone was a waiter it was a writer
yeah you know we were more you know and
we worked very go back and watch like
the waiters and the people eating the
food it's like that's Will Forte you
know what I mean like for something like
the background people yeah and now it's
like one of the featured players who
doesn't get in the show other than
saying mag had you you're minions I mean
you know yeah uh and so I think that was
a difference and I think that
as a cast member you get the more you do
it the the more confident you get the
more relaxed you are oh yeah and I can't
imagine what it's like for one of these
featured players who gets on once every
three weeks or something they have to be
featured in something and the pressure
they must feel yeah as opposed to you
just when they were you know January and
Gala and
Aykroyd and Belushi and Chevy and
um Garrett and and Jamie let Billy
everybody had stuff in the show yeah
and
um and it it
that I think qualitatively is a
difference
is a difference
huh by 4K qualitatively I'm just
enjoying your vocab
okay qualitatively
I did I did well on the SATs that's why
yeah you went to Harvard
you know I grew up in that area
so I in that what area I used to hang
out in Harvard Square all the time yeah
very different but you don't have a
number one accent or my parents do big
time they do really what happened how
did you dodge that or did my father
actually worked really hard and got out
of that Somerville and moved us to as we
like to say hoity-toity Lexington ah
okay yes of course there it goes and
then you get the nice non-regional and
how old were you then I mean my earliest
memories are in that house I mean I
remember being in Melrose for a little
bit but then Lexington okay I see well
my mother and I didn't I didn't hear it
in my mother my father but they really
have it my mom's from Southie like they
oh they have a sure sure my wife's from
Maine and so she has a main accent which
is very different but it has a certain
it has its own charm yeah sure tell me
uh at the beginning before SNL now I
feel like SNL is sort of doing an
impression of what it became like before
at a certain point the die was cast
right but you were there before yeah I
mean the formats the same damn format
it's the same format yeah exactly
well actually the first show was like
maybe you're too young for this you
remember Midnight Special
is that a Midnight Special Wolfman Jack
on Friday nights hosted this show
which was music it was like but and the
our first show we had I think Carlin did
two monologues Valerie Bromfield at a
monologue
um
we had three music guests or something
whoa I mean it was just very and there
was no live from New York I believe
I think it was really yeah I want to
feed your fingertips to the Wolverines
wasn't that I think it was and then it
went live from New York yeah it was
Michael Donahue with Belushi sounds like
a Michael Donna it was a very he's
teaching uh Belushi is from some Eastern
European country and he's teaching him
English
and one of the things here I want to I
want to feed your fingertips to the
Wolverines
and that was the that was the first that
was the first thing on Saturday Night
Watch
and then
O'Donoghue has a heart attack
and Belushi The Immigrant thinks that
that's what he's supposed to do
and he has a heart attack they're both
dead and Chevy came out and went live
from New York on Saturday night oh I
don't know I don't remember that maybe
uh maybe I watched Mad TV maybe it was
the premiere of Mad TV
because they didn't say for Fridays it
might have been Fridays Barry David's
Fridays oh my God Fridays so okay the
format hasn't really changed other than
that first episode which had too many
monologues I'm just gonna say yeah it
just was we did it didn't find and then
then I think the second show might have
been like Paul Simon and our Garfunkel
reuniting or something wow so that was
different I think the first show that
looked like what the show became was
Candice Bergen hosting which was like
the third show or something we started
to get it and
um you know the second say the first
show second season
I
after the show's over I go back up the
17th Floor the phone's ringing I answer
it and some guy goes well the show's
shows terrible that's the end of the
show Saturday night dead
and I'm like that's been going on since
then wait somebody just cold called you
it wasn't yeah this is someone one that
was mad and it was actually a great show
I think it was Lily Tomlin
um black one four one one was the
internet you could just call information
and go get me Saturday Night Live and
then connect you for free yeah they
called him I don't know but
why I answered the damn phone I don't
know hey I answered but I mean that's
what like people say that all they've
been saying that for the whole since the
third episode
what was it I I mean I know there's
always great stuff on the show and
always
is there something you would change
about the format
no
no why would you oh yeah this has worked
for 46 years let's change it
I don't know that's interesting I've
heard good arguments made to make it an
hour
I mean so much of it lives on YouTube
now anyway I know it's very very
different yeah also they pre-tape a lot
they do a lot more pre-taping than we
used to do and what was your chance for
the nervous newcomers to shine actually
is because now they're on the in the
streets and they do some great style the
pre-tapes are
some of them are amazingly yeah
soundingly good yeah and um but
you lose something
to me because it was a live show we
Albert Brooks did a couple some films we
did stuff like that but mainly it was
people running around the studio doing
costume changes in front of the audience
I mean it was much
a little different feel to it circusy
yeah exciting yeah I mean how long would
it take you to go to sleep after tape
night I have to imagine it's well
ridiculous of course the show ends at
one
the chaos has to get out of their
costumes and makeup then you go to a
party
and you get there at 1 30
145 and then you're up till three or
four and you're mainly just talking
about the show yeah you know and coming
down I have to imagine the juice yeah
you're peeking yeah yeah you're supposed
to Peak when you do the show right the
relief that the show went well or at
least the relief that even if it didn't
go well it's over I mean I think there's
a yeah I mean if we did a really good
show we were very happy and if we did a
shitty show we were very down yeah
what what was it like within Paul Simon
got back together
well you mentioned it I'm just like you
were there for that that's incredible I
they got back together again a few times
yeah I mean they've you know reunion
concerts or stuff like that I wasn't
privy to whether I can't remember if
they shared a dressing room I can't I
just
seemed fine it seemed fine yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah super fun beautiful it
was beautiful
what about like a bridge oh isn't that
beautiful song God damn Paul's good I
know an Art Garfunkel was beautiful
beautiful voice no he does have a
beautiful voice and he's great in that
uh Jack Nicholson movie Yes you know
what I'm talking about internal
knowledge yeah I watched I was like art
yeah I think it's the name
and Paul Simon just sounds like a folk
star and I'm sure it was Simon and
non-ski or something of course it was
or Garfunkel and nonsense yeah yeah so
yeah
um and then what happened how did you
eventually work your way into becoming a
performer on the show well um actually
Tom and I
you know kind of or in that audition but
we did yeah the kind of audition for
Lauren there okay well is this a
different Lauren was Lauren different
back then now he seems like yeah this is
46 years ago yeah but was he still scary
I know you know I well you know we were
at our first job and we were yeah and it
was scary you know and we had a six-week
contract
that's a vote of confidence well I know
we had a six-week I think it was six
weeks came standard with a ticket back
to Minnesota today our option was up I I
just kind of went Lauren um and you go
oh Jesus you know and we had written
actually some of the first commercial
parodies and really we're doing fine but
I remember we'd write something and
Lauren would read it and we we'd come in
and go like is this the best thing
you've ever written
and we go no and they go like come back
when it's the best thing you've ever
written and then after we did that like
four or five times we just went like
Jesus Christ of course you can't always
write them back yes like okay I don't
know so did you just start saying yes no
we just he stopped saying it at a
certain point when we went like Lauren
but even I'm thinking there's an iconic
photo it's Belushi and Aykroyd and Chevy
and Lauren backstage in like a kitchen
or something oh I think that might be at
the White House or something oh really I
remember acroy's like looking at a a
carrot it's clearly like he's looking
for some prop to do a bid but it's
before the bits happening anyway Lauren
just looks like one of them like you
know he's got dark hair he's a young man
so what's interesting about that is this
the best thing you've ever written story
is you kind of see the early stages of
that Persona you know Lauren goes home
and is more of a regular guy but when it
comes to corralling comedians he's got I
mean what an achievement he's done I
mean what a mammoth achievement this has
been This is 40 six seasons 47 whatever
it is
and the people have come through that
show I mean it's amazing yeah and the
comedy that I mean it's just do you
think it benefits from having a
withholding father kind of guy
whatever it is you know yeah uh he he's
been you know it's been genius the way
he's done this but do you do better I
know I do if there's someone like I did
a show with Judd and I'll never forget
one time I got a little tipsy with Judd
HBO yes and I accidentally called him
dad and I was like well that's that's a
little on the nose
you know when life is a little on the
news yeah yeah but I realize that's
that's actually good for me one of the
things that motivates me and they don't
have to be as high status as Jed I would
just like to impress somebody that's
withhold like just making me earn uh the
affection or whatever it might be is
that how you're wound
hmm what drives you
or what drove you back then
well
um I think what drove me was just making
ourselves laugh
you know
um
very Jack McBrayer of you I just want to
laugh well you know I I just received
and didn't deserve the Ernie Kovacs
award which is part of the Dallas video
Fest and you know Conan deserves it
is that what you said I'm sure they've
asked them yeah and I didn't deserve it
but I took it anyway but I called Conan
to get his thoughts on on Kovacs and he
just said well the thing about when he
looks at Ernie kopak's stuff is that the
best stuff was always the stuff where he
was just having a gas and making himself
laugh
and I think that was that's what it is
that's what it is the the during covert
going said to me because he couldn't go
into the office he just said the reason
I went into comedy is to be in a room
with funny people that's a good line
yeah yeah and he couldn't be and that's
the and people ask me what's your
favorite memory from SNL and it really
is just three in the morning
on you know Wednesday morning when the
show got ridden we had horrible work
habits
and you know from we didn't really start
writing until like 10 p.m I mean we were
kicking around ideas but really writing
and just rolling on the floor laughing
hmm at something when you know Dana said
or you know
acros or kildo or Downey or
You Know Jack Handy or I mean I did 15
Seasons there so there's a million of
these names you could really say any
name yeah
anyway so you just want to be with funny
people laughing I mean that's that was
sort of it and I remember once a uh a
Critic from I think it was a
Philadelphia Inquirer TV critic goes
like who do you write for what's your
the audience I think she was looking for
a demographic or something and I went no
no no no no you don't understand
you're just trying to get those laughs
in the room
we're making ourselves laugh yeah that's
the only way I think you can
write comedy basically I think I think
good stuff I think I think no I would
agree with that I mean for what it's
worth I I am interested in as cliche as
it is actually SNL made fun of this
podcast once which I obviously took as a
great honor that's huge yeah it is huge
yeah
um that I'm always trying to get at like
some of the psychology of it like a lot
of us are and for me it's definitely
that I was trying to get I lived in a
house where no one was really listening
to me or I didn't feel like I was
getting listened to as much as I was
very very sad yeah there's a sadness to
it there was a lot of uh
yeah take a good look at my face yeah
oh it stands to reason that I would want
to get in a situation my parents were
also always arguing so I wanted to
defuse arguments this is like Classic
this is like right out of the card
catalog you know when you pull it out
there's comedian stop the fight
um be heard and I wanted that that uh
guttural that physical uh confirmation
that I had been heard not just um but I
wanted to make you roll over with
laughter and I was like I exist I'm here
they laughing they understand stuff my
parents would laugh at me yeah they were
they were Charmed with me they weren't
my biggest fans and and they're they're
still not really sure what's happening
that's not to say they don't like it and
they don't support me they do but
they've come to my shows I've said this
before and I can see them in the
audience and they're just they're just
looking around they can't believe
everyone's laughing wow not in a bad way
they just they're not really hip-hop
they don't have the sensibilities that
somehow you develop yes they would love
it both
if my mom went on stage and told a joke
in fact if my mom makes a joke just like
me earlier and you don't laugh she'll go
that was a very funny say hahaha say
very funny mama and she won't move on
until you like tell her like you did
jokingly to me like that was good thank
you oh okay I'll give you an example
they just visited my mom goes well
that's a very pretty ceiling and I just
went huh and she went usually you would
say something in return about I just
said it was a pretty ceiling and I was
like I don't know what's going on accent
is that that's not yeah
that's like my brothers I think the
persons whose accent you're doing just
died
this accent no longer exists what's
Natasha listening okay oh it's the queen
it was a queen oh I see I thought you
were just saying the last person that
spoke that way just died oh I see I see
yeah I could have foul but so
you you can't necessarily and you don't
have to identify anything other than a
love of Comedy uh for wanting to get
into it for the compulsion to do it
because there are some just funny people
that work in sandwich shops they laugh
with their friends all day oh I was
ambitious you know that kind of stuff
but I thought I was at the right place I
mean I was on you know we're just like
Jesus Christ look where we are you mean
getting on SNL yeah but you had to
really uh well you didn't really know
what it was that's an interesting
question how did you find out what SNL
was and that they were hiring I didn't I
didn't uh Tom and I have been doing
stand-up at The Comedy Store
and uh William Morris agent herb carp uh
I know yeah
like he came he just said why don't you
come to my office and he said you guys
are okay fine smoking he's smoking
I don't I don't think her was smoking
but anyway
um he uh would you guys be interested in
writing for like TV variety or and we
said yeah but there's nothing on right
now that we could write for and
basically it was Carson who was a really
great show but we are not right for that
we couldn't we're not Carson Mighty art
players writers yeah and not model you
know not that kind of monologue writing
and then there was Carol Burnett which
is a great show but just generationally
we were completely wrong for it and
there was sunny and Cher which was kind
of crappy so it was not very good and so
they said well why don't you write a
package of material for a show you'd
like to
C and I like to write for and we did we
wrote a newscast we wrote a commercial
parody we wrote A Sketch which was a
parody of Sonny and Cher and then we did
a conceptual film and it was 14 pages
long and this is for people listening
for young people listening who want to
write and submit packages of material it
doesn't have to be 50 page it can be
this you know you can tell people can
tell after a page right and sometimes
that's all they're going to read is
especially these Oscars you're going to
go okay I know yeah right so you wrote
14 pages at 14 pages change your life
and invented SNL question mark well it
sounds like I'm claiming that
go ahead but Lauren Lauren we were the
only writers Lauren higher that he he
did not meet oh no meeting yeah we
weren't yeah because you're in L.A we're
in LA but I guess you you know I mean a
number of the people he had met before
because he had been in La too remember
he did laugh and then he did Lily Tomlin
specials I think in L.A do you remember
anything from the packet
yeah I remember the newscast was a
newscast on the night of the day of
World War III
well the tragedy death catastrophe I
like tonight's news after this message
and Anna was a commercial Perry and then
it was
well today it happened World War III
um let's see something about uh
you know the killing 120 million
Russians and you know uh 1.7 billion
Chinese
really and now with the sports Barney
Johnson or with the weather temperatures
up to 8 000 degrees and that is so funny
in the valley today oh no 8 000 degrees
say 8040 in the valley I think it was it
was the local LA News
something like that and that that was
Sports Barney Johnson
as soon as you name World War II World
War II
like a franchise you do since then we've
been worrying about World War III yeah
what hasn't happened yet that's right
[__] God and World War one wasn't
called it was called the Great War yeah
I think it was now but yeah and then it
was retroactively rebranded as World War
One
and world war three will be so I wrote a
sketch with Downey and some other people
kicked in great jokes but it was comedy
Killers I don't know if it was like
Jeopardy and the categories were like uh
the Kennedys
the Holocaust like things you can't
answer blah blah and Downey wrote this
great joke which was the Final Jeopardy
final Jeff or final comedy killer Donna
and the category was the greatest comedy
killer of all time
and none of the contestants got it right
and the answer was
the assassination of Archduke Ferdinand
very specific isn't that a [__] great
joke yeah yeah yeah and yet I still
recently not this year but before prepan
I would be brought up after like footage
of cancer and nothing wrong with footage
of cancer patients it's just not right
to go ladies and Gentlemen The Comedy
settings you know it's like it's not
like you'd think it would be the
opposite actually like this you're
saying you can't you do a fundraiser or
something and they show the video of all
the good workers yeah burn units you
don't want to do that for a burger it's
true that's exactly my point oh boy
that's the word did you I've done it
before and then
Al Franken like you just want to say
like just for the sake of everything
like it's not like sometimes I envy
musicians I feel like a musician could
go out and play following a sad video
like that would be okay unless you're
like
[__] Jimmy Buffett or something like
it's like
[__] you man people are dying like
that's not I'm gonna work yeah I think
he has a couple go-to's that he can do
like they're a little I actually think I
just made a mistake I don't think he
sings if you like pina coladas I think
that's someone else no no he does
Margaritas Margarita but it's the same
category of tropical drinks anytime sour
mix and rum are getting in a blender
Jimmy Buffett's nearby yeah yeah
okay when we come back we'll shift gears
we are going to go to a short break
we're gonna come back and we'll talk
about the second part of your career
which I'm still confused how that
happened I know he probably talked about
it a lot but we're going to talk about
it move into politics when we come back
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at raycon wireless earbuds lately I've
been listening to a lot of Father Greg
Boyle's audiobooks uh on my iPhone and
when I do it's been an absolute pleasure
a lot because the books are incredible
obviously but in huge part because when
I do I listen to them on my raycon
wireless earbuds raycon everyday earbuds
look feel and sound better than ever
with optimized gel tips for a perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me I often wear these earbuds when
I'm on my treadmill which means my body
is moving quite a bit and they stay put
and they sound fantastic raycons give
you eight hours of play time and a 32
hour battery life raycons are also
priced just right you get quality audio
at half the price of other premium audio
Brands it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over 50
000 five-star reviews they have three
customizable sound profiles earbud tap
functions noise isolations everything
you get in the super super expensive
ones you get them in raycon just as
great feeling sounding and looking
amazing I absolutely love them they keep
in place they sound great and you don't
have to spend an arm and a leg to get
high high high quality audio and you can
show your support of this podcast so go
to byraycon.com today and use code
weirdo 15 to get 15 off your raycon
order that's code weirdo 15 at buy
r-a-y-con.com to score 15 off buy
raycon.com code weirdo 15. if you're
listening to podcasts you might as well
do it in Comfort with great audio
quality and with all the fun functions
that you could possibly dream of by
raycon.com and use promo code weirdo 15.
all right guys back to the show
we're back there's no time that passes
for us I understand that I understand
how that works
I'm not stupid
the guy that thinks everything is about
him I know how it works
um
you well I actually before we get into
politics
I mean pick a name who there's so many
people that you worked with was there
great comedy advice all these people
that you worked with or a moment
somebody telling you you're doing a good
job you're on the right track I mean
pick a name from the Litany of people
that you worked with Dan Aykroyd pulls
you aside gives you a cigarette and says
frank and beans he called you frank and
beans right you're gonna be okay or
something
no I can't I well we have more ads
actually
I'm trying to well what about a lesson
that you know Steve Martin once saw
something I did I did the White House
correspondence dinner and he said
something like you should do that kind
of thing I mean really yeah yeah like
you're in your element yeah or was that
pre-sented or post oh no no no way
pretty pretty you didn't even mean that
he just meant I think he was saying you
should do Weekend Update and I didn't
get it so oh wait that's fine what about
comedy advice you're watching how these
different people work like all the
different strategies what did you absorb
from watching the different writing
styles performance styles
all right again again it's like to me
it's like
um the only reason to do comedy is if
you have to
and if you have to you'll just
do it and don't worry about
you know getting your the worst thing
you can do is get 20 minutes together
go to The Comedy Store or somewhere and
then just do that 20 minutes yeah that's
that's just seeing that happen oh it
still happens yeah yeah and so
let's try to figure out a process and
and be patient with yourself
you know it's a long slog you know it's
at 10 000 hours thing you know yeah I'm
not familiar with I'm just kidding what
if I I'm the one person that doesn't
know that yeah ten thousand hours and
then where do you remember
the moment when you're like I think I'm
gonna go for this like I'm gonna try and
become a senator
oh Santa
um
yeah I do remember the time I thought
about doing it and
um Paul wellstone was
um senator from Minnesota he got elected
in
um
in uh 92
and an upset Victory and he was a great
Progressive uh
Senator he's a friend of mine and two
thousand two he was running for
re-election and he was in a dead heat
with Norm Coleman
and he had to vote in October
on the Iraq War
and he was going to vote against it in
the large majority of minnesotans were
four going to war
and Paul told me
this is probably going to be the end of
my career because he was in a neck and
neck race
and he voted against it and the next
poll that came out had him up by seven
oh wow went the other way because it
went the other way because minnesotans
respect
a politician who votes his conscience
and his plane went down
and with
Paul and his wife and his daughter and
three aides and two pilots died
and Coleman ended up winning the race
and three months after he Norm Coleman
got into office he did a
interview with roll call which is a
Capitol Hill newspaper and he said to be
blonde I'm a 99 improvement over Paul
wellstone
and I said who the [__] is going to beat
this guy hmm
so
that's very West Wing I don't mean to
make light of this person who died or
anything but when it gets personal like
that there's a West Wing moment where
someone puts down Martin Sheen someone
who died it's almost it might have been
inspired by this for all I know and he
was like well guess what game on like
now it's personal sort of thing yeah
it's not a fire under you yeah and
that's not a reason to run for the
Senate I guess but uh I moved back to
Minnesota
and
um I in 2006 I just campaigned for
Democrats who were running in the state
and I found that crowds would turn out
for me
and so I decided to go for it because of
Comedy I think because of Comedy I also
written these books like Rush Limbaugh
is a big fat idiot and other
observations which was
I I've written four number one New York
Times bestsellers wow not to brag about
my phone what do you pull down for
number one huh what do you pull down for
those those are there it's it's good
it's good
lies in the langliners is the biggest
and that uh that was about fox and fox
sued me oh wow thank you so my wife
wanted to get a band a marching band to
go in front of fox going thank you very
much boom thank you very much
nicest thing that any I mean it was
amazing because it put so much attention
everyone had to read yeah and they were
laughed out of court they they the title
of the book was lies and lying Liars who
tell them a fair and balance look at the
right and so they sued me for copyright
or tried to stop the book from being
published because of quote copyright
fair and balanced fair and balance and
the thing is is that the case law is
clear that if you're if the thing if the
title is is something you're actually
writing about it's fine
so right they were just
laughed out of court and but O'Reilly
was so mad at me for I had made I
made him really look bad at a Book Expo
and that he insisted they sue and it was
it was an O'Reilly suit they had to do
it too they had to please please him
yeah and I'm uh Floyd Abrams who was
number one you know uh First Amendment
lawyer in the country took my case he'd
done Pentagon papers and all that kind
of stuff
and he calls me up and he told me not to
go to court you know for it he said we
won I said Floyd a chimp could have won
this
and later there was a documentary he
made about the case and he wrote and he
was interviewed he said a monkey could
have won this
and I call him up I go I did say monkey
I said chimp and he said what's the
difference like a little chimp is funny
monkey isn't
chimp a chimp even MailChimp which is a
sponsor is funny I'm just kidding
they're not a sponsor that chimp is
funnier also close and he testified once
in front of the uh I was on the
Judiciary Committee okay I wasn't I'm
not a lawyer but I played one in a
sketch that's all I wanted to say and uh
Floyd was satisfying and I just made him
have to I told that story or made him
you got it right on the record I got it
on the record it's in the Congressional
Record
yeah and he misquoted me
so you decide to go for it for this
beautiful reason you get sued for your
books that you made a lot of money for
then you run and I it was a very very
close race 312 votes I clobbered him it
was the narrowest club ring in history
You collaborated by 312 books roughly an
IHOP like a full IHOP
this recount we I actually won the
recount in time to be seated with my
colleagues but the Republicans went to
court and uh delayed me like six months
but when I got there it was the 60th
Democratic vote and those six years
Democratic senator so that's how we got
the Affordable Care Act and did you I
don't care for that act did you
did you have any imposter syndrome I
mean people have imposter syndrome for
Less
for some reason I didn't and for I think
it was basically that
I knew why I was doing it
and uh and what it ceased to be you know
revenge or something but I knew I was
doing I was doing it for all the right
reasons
it's similar to your very pure and to me
sometimes challenging
just love of Comedy like you just wanted
to do comedy because you just want to
laugh and you just want to do what makes
you laugh and make people laugh that's
that's a very pure intent yeah but I
really kind of think that's any good
comedian that's that's what it is right
yeah and I'm not sure that every
politician I when goes into it for the
same reasons I hear you I went in I'm
challenged by that just because I know
when I'm off axis it's because I'm doing
comedy because it makes me high and when
I'm on access I'm I'm feeling good and
I'm in the flow and doing good work to
be honest it's because I'm going on
stage because I want to make everybody
laugh not for the feeling you get from
making people laugh does that make sense
that makes a lot of sense but when I I'm
with you I got into this because I want
to do what makes me laugh but then it
gets very tempting to get it's the ring
of power tolkien's ring of power now
you're like oh this gets me this gets me
off yeah then that can become your new
reason to do it right and my wife has to
recalibrate me every once in a while and
she's like
okay you didn't like it but didn't you
do your job didn't you make them laugh
like you're like it's not really about
you being like I'm a Golden Boy you know
what I mean which clearly is my wound
not yours
I'm sorry you have to live that way
put that on you in a strange moment and
what a great response so you got into it
for the right reasons going back to what
we were saying about being on the subway
why don't more politicians or maybe they
do now because of social media whatever
but there does seem to be a lack of
performance Show Business basic
public speaking stuff like is that
changing are people becoming Slicker or
more polished no I mean I I think if
anything people are just too programmed
to
uh consultant driven
and there is a certain sameness
you know
um and
I mean this is why Trump wanting for
because we had that that entertainment
because he yeah and he you know he was
running a member when he ran in the
primaries of 16 all the other guys
or there was a number of reasons first
of all Trump's rallies were incredibly
entertaining to watch right so CNN would
just cut to them right and so would Emma
NBC because how could you take your eyes
off this right thing and and he you know
uh in the podcast did with Sarah uh we
were talking about how he was like a
stand-up and he could rip well at that
line sorry to interrupt he did remember
he called covid I'm not endorsing this
joke I do I'm saying it like Tom I do
not like this joke it's a terrible joke
but he called covet Kung flew and
Chappelle's joke about that was why is
he saying that I'm supposed to be saying
that and and that is sort of to your
point like what is this like what's
happening well he was like riffing and
whatever and he could do that and none
of these other guys could do anything
like that and all their if you see a
debate he would just insult them and
they would do these talking points that
were exactly what you're talking about
which is just you can't listen to them
really at a certain point especially
when there's like 10 people in a debate
and they each get a minute and they each
that's right given a minute we're
certain team answer by a consultant and
they've memorized it and they rattle it
off and you know and he would just uh
make fun of them you know yeah and he
would call them you know low energy Jeb
or right right Little Marco and all that
[__] right and people would go wow I
like that crooked Hillary is pretty easy
to remember yeah and
um again I just think that
you know uh build the wall and make and
Mexico pay for it was his Hot Pockets
you know his gavigan Hot Pockets yeah it
was just closer he just he just said it
and
uh the response he got I'm not sure it
was not a public policy that he had
thought through yeah and of course he
said Mexico would pay for it right right
it didn't matter and
um
so
that's why he won because he didn't talk
like everybody else it reminded me it's
a lot a part of it you know see he
tapped in the Deep resentment people
have
and that a lot of people have in our the
disillusionment and all that well
they're you know it was a certain point
people start getting really pissed off
that their kids aren't doing better than
they did right which had kind of been
the promise
that we had had since
you know the end of World War II yes
what is I know this is a big thing to
put on you but we're just two guys
talking yeah is the answer
do we need a flat like okay Roy Wood Jr
talk about other comedians has a joke
about like you can't beat crazy with
Satan you have to the only way to be
crazy is not crazier yeah that's why he
liked Bernie uh Bernie was just kind of
liberal crazy enough to be like we're
gonna well they would probably yeah very
passionate and but he's also going to
give everybody health care and college
is going to be free like that's sort of
like that's called three there's one by
the Millionaires and the billionaires
and then in 2019 it turns out that he's
a millionaire well I had to change his
stump speech and he had the toughest
time doing it was that a problem well he
came by it honestly he had written some
uh best-selling books not number one New
York Times but selling books like me
which by the way makes you a millionaire
so what's the problem yeah yeah well
okay put that out not joking no you
don't have to cut that out I wasn't
trying to shots fired no no no no it's
just what I'm saying I was sitting here
assuming Bernie Sanders was a
millionaire he's he's been in you know
Show Business public office well no no
you don't get believe me you don't the
salary for a senator is
exactly what it is right now it's about
two hundred thousand dollars and you
know you have to have two residences it
uh you know some some of the Senators
have their spouse be a lobbyists I mean
there's other ways uh for them to make
money but if you're
um no they're my colleagues
don't you know didn't that's interesting
uh didn't have a lot of money well I
might be a a dingus but I just was like
anybody that's that recognizable must be
making a lot doing public speaking no we
can't do public speaking you can't get
paid the publicly speak no they used to
do that they still they stopped doing
that I didn't know that for good reason
yeah but you can write a book you can
write a book yeah so Bernie had written
these books is that how he did it yeah
that's how he did it so what's uh what's
the big deal
no big deal but anyway the point was all
the thing was the this country was run
by the Millionaires and the billionaires
because politicians rely on Millionaires
and billionaires for the donation and
and then he had to start saying like
this country is run by the
the billionaires and multi-billionaires
and then he had a heart attack doing it
remember he had a heart attack in 2019.
well it's hard to shift gears
but it's very interesting I don't I
don't know
he's still not the one percent I don't
know why I'm getting hung up on this
it's like can't you still be against the
the the unfair disbursement of wealth
and be a millionaire I I of course and
again he came by it honestly and he's
but he also would want himself to be
taxed right fairly he's going against
his best interest yeah yeah which is
um
this is the Republican party I mean
Republican party but which is so weird
because they are always you know
tapping into the resentment of people
who live in red areas where things
aren't
the economy isn't doing well and people
are
you know saying my kids aren't going to
do better than me and they're they
resent the elites and there's reasons to
resent Elites there's you know
at least can be self-serving certainly
in Washington but that's the odd part
about it is is that they're trying to
tap into that but the Republican party
is doing the the
acting the will of the very of the Koch
brothers of the the very wealthy right
and they're they cut taxes on the
wealthy that's what Trump did right
after running
you know supposedly for working people
right and so no but Bernie yeah he came
by and honestly he wrote these books but
he would tax himself at a much higher
rate and so going back to my Roy wood
and people should be able to make money
people should be able to
I I once I I had this idea for Bernie
Sanders everyone I would I would preside
you know you present when you're in the
majority you preside uh Senate and you
call on
um and every once I just daydream and I
thought of uh if Bernie Sanders had a
right-wing identical twin
a crazy right-wing identical twin and so
it'd be like uh chair recognizes the
center from Vermont
is my party got crazy what creates jobs
of of entrepreneurs who risk the capital
and take chances and create jobs for
hard work in America and Sir excuse me
are you not actually Senator Sanders but
his crazy right-wing identical twin yes
I am well I'm afraid sir I'm gonna have
to ask the sergeant of arms to have you
removed that's all right
but I'll be back because they can't tell
us apart
so that Cerny banders huh Cerny banners
Arnie Arnie Sanders
I didn't say I'll be back yeah I'll be
back they can't tell us apart
and
[Laughter]
fantastic my original Roy Wood Junior
question though is do we need there's a
lot of threads to go down here
you're in charge yeah I know I have to
pick which one's more interesting and
I'm gonna forget the other one but do we
need more crazy to fight crazy like do
you do we need Tom Hanks to come out and
Hanks is hardly crazy no I know but okay
do you need Tom Hanks to be crazy no no
do we need a huge famous do you like
when I say crazy I mean splashy loud
Oprah Tom Hanks Tom Cruise somebody that
can go in and give me Alaska I won was
Joe Biden yeah but that was the anybody
but Trump here yeah and the next one
unfortunately may be the anybody but
Trump here too right I mean we're on a
really odd edge here where he could be
indicted for you know the the uh keeping
these uh top secret documents at his
Resort or for you know all the tax [__]
he did in New York or that that's a
legal suit but believe me the Manhattan
prosecutor is going to be looking at
that or for what you know the
raffensberger call All I need is 11 780
votes and you'll be in trouble if I you
don't do that
and then of course for January 6th and
the the clear
uh he knew you know he'd been totally
lost he knew he lost and the fake
electors and the putting pressure I mean
and then on the one hand we're there
that's there and on the other hand oh
it's not you know we've always counted
them out we counted them out
millions of times and we're at like a
precipice here it feels like yeah
it does seem to be the age of nothing
matters like I feel like anything it's
amazing what didn't matter with him
right and it reminds me I've said this
before but I want to say it to you and
like it has drunk dad energy you know
what I mean it's like the the family
member that keeps
crashing his car driving drunk or burned
down the schoolhouse and like for some
reason that like ah that Dad thing that
is codependency kind of dynamic there
which is
you know alcoholic dad is crazy but I'm
I just if he's in a good mood that's
good that's right maybe is it a bad mood
I'm I'm afraid keep him in a good mood
yeah and maybe we'll get what he yeah
and also what also really happened was
my former Republican colleagues caved
every one of them and they saw what
happened if you didn't
of Jeff Flake from Arizona what's in my
name right there he's gonna he's gonna
flake's not going to let you not let you
down
his name's flake oh I see
scattles
puns to me are the highest
Katie laughed form comedy
because he's a flake You See
oh no anyway I'm sorry
they went the wrong way well they just
all caved them and you know I have
former Republican colleagues who I talk
to and I go like why won't you
acknowledge publicly that the election
was not stolen and and basically it's
because they'll lose their primary wow
and you'll get someone crazier than me
and I say the key word is crazier
this is the opposite of of the man who
voted against the Iraq War yeah before
which by the way Wilson forgive me that
what a lesson in Legacy you know what I
mean like we're so short-sighted we they
don't care yeah we don't care about
their legacy yeah I don't care
that's that's that's the interesting
thing yeah that I've discovered that
they don't care
just want to have be in office and get
the perks and have the power or you know
more you know Lindsey Graham who by the
way is the funniest senator
uh now
um sort of like being the sexiest
librarian though it kind of is
[Laughter]
um
but I believe the librarian in
um uh music videos in in the in the uh
the music man was kind of oh I looked it
was a looker there's something sexy
about being shushed I'm gonna say it
yeah
I like that I won you back finally
a long period there anyway
what was I talking about anyway uh yeah
they um
like Lindsay just you know he said that
he was a pathological liar and
xenophobe are you talking about caring
not caring about your legacy just one
yeah yeah and he did he completely 180
you know he's in a 180. yeah on Trump
because it was and he wanted to be part
of he wanted to be a player and he
wanted to keep his senate seat in South
Carolina he had to be a trump supporter
to keep your senate seat hmm
frightening frightening
um here's another one more political
question then we'll get to the meaning
of life if that's okay with you
okay
um it's not
no one's going to be helped by asking me
that question by your outlook on the
meaning of life because I I don't know
if I have a profound oh you don't need a
profound one
we'll just be two guys talking okay
um which I think is a good thing to do
um just in itself whether or not we
figured out which we won't so let's just
let take that onus off of ourselves do
you think
we'll figure out
big things gun control the environment
are you optimistic or do you just so
many people I talk to are just like well
I think we made some progress on gun
control tell me after Vivaldi
people I mean
they actually did a bipartisan Bill
completely not enough but made it harder
for someone
to get an assault weapon if they've had
some kind of mental health you know red
flag laws where someone can call in and
say this guy shouldn't have a gun and
um I did a podcast with one of the
um parents from Sandy Hook who has
started this thing called San Diego
promise and she was involved in the
negotiations it was a bipartisan deal
um some good things in it
some focus on Mental Health
but yeah we're I mean there's no reason
to have assault weapons there's just no
reason to have assault weapons and
um
you know people you know I people say oh
we go hunting with him well you don't
really need assault weapon to go hunting
um people did shoot deer before there
were assault weapons right and you know
they uh
there's got to be a limit to so but
there's some progress and people are fed
up people are fed up yeah and uh again
though it's
um
uh it it's still Republicans in States
you know like Texas and stuff like that
it will not
I'm gonna go there isn't it not and
you're really talking to a Rube here but
like
if I know it
first Katie choke tank that was a choke
tape that was great
I mean doesn't it it seems pretty
obvious to me that it's not really about
guns right
all of this to me is tied up in
Psychology and parents and your father
told you that Liberty was having this I
used to have a joke where I was like I
think the way they feel about guns is
the way that East Coast West Coast
Elites feel about their cell phones you
know what I mean like no well everybody
feels about theirselves exactly for sure
yeah but that's how I can relate but
like it's not about needing a gun to
shoot a deer it's about that feeling of
no one tells me what to do yep right
it's and that gets mixed in with Liberty
personal freedom and all that sort of
stuff so oh I mean there was a
surprising percentage of people believe
we need these weapons and so the case of
them they can fight the government back
yeah which but even that whenever I hear
any of these excuses I just hear and I'm
not even trying to put them down like an
alcoholic saying like I just like
drinking at a ball game you know what I
mean just like no really it's about
alcohol which you're tied to it is
emotional and and murky and it's like we
need Freud to get in here it's it's been
con conflated you know it's so funny I I
uh last night I went to a Rosh Hashanah
dinner and this is all anyone I mean
this is what we talk about is this
divide yeah and the source of it and
when it started and how it's gotten so
bad
and it's a it's sort of the
the overriding conversation
that in you know people who care about
this stuff have and how do we move from
where we are to somehow moving back to
where this wasn't like this so at least
so bad that's always existence some of
this a lot of this stuff always has but
it and and I do think that there are a
lot of factors social media uh where
people get their information I think it
has it has to do with a lot a lot a lot
of identity too you even said Texas it's
like if you want to be a belong to a
tribe I don't even know if it's all of
Texas but you want to belong to a tribe
you feel this way and again that's why
I'm always going like it's your dad
someone's saying like I'm going to
control
I'm going to tell you your dead dad is
wrong or I'm gonna you know what I mean
I think so
um I'm saying it's way more personal
anybody would see oh it's all I mean but
again you can tell it depends what
community you live in where you're
getting your information so it is
necessarily
and what's interesting is
you know I talk about crews in my show
and I have a whole Ted Cruz section
cruise control
okay now we like buttons no
[Laughter]
no still no no it was a Badoo
anyway
it was fun it was a neutral
you're an open book and I like it yes
okay
okay so for that terrible fun no I mean
um and one of the things I talk about is
remember Cancun
and he Texas has frozen over and he
takes a four-day vacation a year or he's
going to take a four-day vacation it
gets caught in the airport someone
videotapes him with a roller bag and
he's photographed on the plane he lands
and the staff calls him we got trouble
and then he lies he says I just going
for I just dropped the girls off coming
right back to help
and he wasn't he he had actually been on
a group chat and asked other families to
join them for a four day vacation in
Cancun at the Ritz-Carlton and normally
when you invite people to do have a
vacation with you they're friends and
you're usually friends don't immediately
go to the New York Times right that's
right and text them and the text anyway
but uh Ben Shapiro is this right-wing
guy uh the big right-wing guy said well
what could he do anyway
everyone back and there's plenty you
could do you're one of only two Federal
Statewide elected officials you have a
big staff
you're in touch with FEMA the Federal
Emergency Management agency you can do
stuff there's stuff you can do but one
of the things is you can do is learn a
lot about people and I saw people who I
have
no in areas that I know are Trump areas
where there was a flood
and you see people step up and I
remember this one couple this is it was
96 degrees it was a community
south of Duluth
and just
this flood
and this family these two the couple
they're in their 40s I'd say lost their
their house because the foundation
crumbled and I was talking to them
they're sweating it's 96
um
saying like well you know we were
thinking of moving to Missouri because
we have family there but you know what
these kids these teenagers came
and spent the entire weekend
hauling the stuff or stuff that was that
ruined
to the dumpsters and we decided this is
our community
and you go like you know what
they're [__] good people on both
sides
and we just got to find a way to tap
into that but that's what you see you
see people step up churches putting
people up you see other people putting
other people up who lost their home you
see all kinds of
amazing things and and when you're a
senator you represent the whole state
you know you represent everybody and you
meet everybody and I love that I love
that part of it
um so did it increase your compassion
and understanding
uh it increased my understanding
tremendously of people and of
you know
um again of how
you know people are can be just great
yeah
it's funny individuals are it's a it's a
gift to be able to meet individuals you
know spend time with people instead of
masses you know masses are difficult and
in a situation that's why you know what
can he do anyway
you can also tell people this is how you
keep track of what you've lost and so
you can get this is a federal disaster
you're going to get reimbursed for this
stuff but you got to keep records of and
that gives them hope yeah you know I
mean there's stuff you can do on all
different kinds of levels yeah
there's a water treatment plant that
lost its in in Texas they lost all their
power
but you can get a you could get FEMA to
get a diesel generator there
to clean so they could go back to making
clean water because no one had clean
water yeah you can do [__] yeah yeah
yeah but you also learn a lot
um
I love that I love that I I feel free to
say no as you have but is there a memory
you have of meeting people that clearly
disagreed with you politically and saw
you as a New York Showbiz uh jerk face
and then they loved you and they let you
in they didn't see me as that they're
just some the ones who didn't like me
well maybe some but I'm just kidding
mainly it was I just you know there I
remember going to a guy in in way up uh
Northwest Minnesota
who had a business which was making out
outdoor furnaces or something wood
burning furnaces for the Eight houses
and was very successful at doing that
and they had this big
kind of uh where how he had this big
place and every every room had Fox on
every room just running on tap if you
walked in any room was Fox
and I was talking to him and he
[Music]
um
he was creating jobs for people and he
was creating a really good product and
um at one point he he I he was working
on
a a mower he was developing a new Mower
and that swiveled 100 360 degrees
and I went Jesus Christ and I go
uh what are you gonna
do you have a name for it and he goes no
I don't yet I go well what about the
swivel
and he goes [__]
[__]
Democrats Democrat just thought of a
good name for my [__]
[Laughter]
and there it is and I just like laughed
and he you know he knew why I was
laughing and then he laughed yeah and uh
same thing uh there's a thing they're
two Farm organizations one the Farmers
Union which is the progressive
organization and then there's the Farm
Bureau okay and Minnesota one out of six
jobs are tied to AG so the Farm Bureau
is much bigger and very conservative
and
um but you know I represented Minnesota
and there are certain issues that I
voted with them on uh for both both the
farm Pharmacy Farm Bureau so one like my
second year there I got this award from
the Farm Bureau from the conservatives
it was like the friend of the farmer
plaque
so I'm with
um with the head of the Farm Bureau
Kevin Papp
he's a farmer near Mankato Minnesota
South Central Minnesota and so I'm
getting a picture taken and I go Kevin I
can't tell you how much this means to me
goes like it's just the way you voted
ah and I just went like I laughed
and then he understood right away what
he had just done and what he had said
and we became instant friends and I just
gave him [__] about that for years years
and then he invited me to his farm to
harvest the Franken five that was the
last five acres of corn that were
harvested wow and uh and you know and he
and I are just really good friends oh I
love that yeah what great answers
all right meaning of life meaning of
Lifetime
uh
uh dead over you think it's I'm just
with you I'm jumping right to the end
okay when you die lights out
oh oh I don't know I don't know
um have you had any ghosty experiences
any near-death experience no
um any reason to think
I don't know I mean I think this is a
mystery and
I completely
have no I I don't know and I know that
I think you have a soul I think and I
think the fact that human beings exist
is some kind of
uh odd [__] anomaly and I don't know
how this all started I don't I have a
big I don't know on all of this I really
don't I'm not religious at all I try to
be spiritual I try what does that mean
what was that mean yeah means try to
connect to something
that tells me
what's best for
me and the people around me
you mean it's like a higher power like a
higher power yeah and
um I don't even know what it means but I
try to connect it sometimes if I
meditate I connect gotta get closer to
that but there's something there maybe
there's something or maybe it's just
[__] physics you know
and I I can't you know I
keep wanting to go like how can the
universe be finite
we still haven't figured that out I
gotta talk to some astrophysicist and he
has to explain that or she has to
explain that to me do they say it's
funny yeah
I thought it was expanding it's
expanding but it's finite
that sounds infinite
[Laughter]
keep expanding
forever and ever well I don't that's a
good question but uh they say it's
finite
so I'll go like what yeah
um yeah that that this is a real lava
lamp conversation but it's like what's
on the other side of the expanding lava
lamp meaning
you've got the lava lamp yeah yeah but
you know if oh man you know maybe
like
every atom
is its own Universe I mean not bad
that's a lava lamp you can what what I
it totally is what I find more pressing
and more
um experientially investigatable
is does your Consciousness when you
close your eyes when you meditate is
there any border a past which your
Consciousness doesn't exist
like in the same way that the universe
is this endless seeming thing so too is
your inner awareness your inner reality
and when and you don't have to take my
word for it when you're meditating you
go like where where is this does it have
a beginning does it have an end was the
phenomenon of awareness was it born does
it die is it personal these are
interesting questions wow what is it
that to where you meditate a lot better
than I do no what is it that's aware of
my experience is a good question too
like what is it that that knows you're
looking at me and you know it but what
what knows that well now I'm going to
listen to this podcast I want to figure
out what you just said
the final question my dear friend
um is we sort of touched on it at the
beginning
the time you laughed the hardest in your
life can you think of it
I know you said in the writer's room
maybe there's a time with your there are
two things I can think of right off the
bat
uh in
um Steve Martin's movie
uh [__] what's the name of it well it's
the one with uh Eddie Murphy Bowfinger
Bowfinger
when he sends Eddie Murphy across the
highway the freeway
I my eyes almost popped out of my head I
was laughing so hard
and then there was one and I had the
literal feeling of my eyes May pop out
of my head now I'm laughing so hard and
I had the same experience of that when I
was uh writing co-writing a book with
Billy Kimball who's a brilliant writer
and we were working really hard on this
book
and uh I went we went to Canyon Ranch
just a right
and we're writing really really writing
and he had been a consultant at Comedy
Central at the time
and he just said like how sometimes
they'll get submissions or something of
an idea and that sometimes someone will
say they'll just submit an idea and goes
it writes itself
yes and we had been working so hard and
very productively and but
I just laughed so hard at that that how
dumb that is yes that my eyes almost
popped out of my head and that's
literally if you ask me that's the
hardest you ever laughed those are the
two times yeah well that's like
they're all those writers room folklore
stories and one of them is it's always
someone unqualified writer in a room and
one of them was um Hanging with Mr
Cooper and apparently someone who hadn't
really pitched the whole season goes it
was quiet and they go Cooper comes home
house burned down
springboard like that like that's them
saying it writes itself like if the
opening
his house burned down it writes itself
like what's he gonna do he's got no
house it also reminds me of by the
Netflix building on Sunset here there's
somebody some
Beautiful Soul put up hey I'm saying
something nice put up a billboard that
is like Netflix have you seen it I have
a spy Thriller for you it is a lord
can't miss series and like and there's
two of them there's two Billboards and I
was like I always because I'm an
optimist I always go what if it is
incredible like what if and what are the
chances of that zero yes
absolute zero which is the name of the
series absolutely
well Al this was a a real thrill like I
said I I was nervous to do it and and
here I was nothing about it well I told
you about my dream oh that's right I
wasn't like actively nervous I just my
unconscious was like yeah okay you know
you're you've done a lot in your life
well I was I was calm coming into this
one well I'm glad I'm glad you were
comfortable I was happy I was excited
actually I was excited oh were you
really no but I was kind of uh looking
forward to you made me crazy that's when
you look at the camera
no I was I was very much looking forward
to it well that's very good and I
appreciate it and you're a millionaire
would you would you we closed the show
with the guests saying keep it crispy
it's just the catchphrase I promise it's
not a political trap okay
keep it crispy
I'll give you a little bit of Christmas
baby
thank you very much that is a first that
someone gave us four alts yeah 600 plus
episodes first time really yes there you
go there you go that's the genius of the
man
that was excellent
[Music]